first on cbs this morning we are excited
to have the two-time gold medalist with
us at the table ashley
good morning and i got to start here can
we feel that medal because
i touch your mouth so heavy i mean
it's an olympic gold medal it's so heavy
i oh my god it really is
you to have two of these can you do you
have perspective now on what that means
i mean it's so interesting because
everyone fixates on the metal but the
metal is just like a representation of
this whole journey it's so beautiful and
it means so much to me but
it's like all of the hard work of the
past five years of the previous four
years that goes into building
that metal in like a figurative sense
that um
really really is what we're going to
hold on to and this just represents all
of that it's so interesting to see the
past five years of course instead of the
past four years because you went through
this grieving process you say after the
olympics were delayed what was it like
with that kind of extra year you had to
stay fit for yeah there were a lot of um
it was it was hard to adjust it was hard
like you said um there's a grieving the
loss of the olympics we didn't know
there was so much uncertainty about
whether the olympics would actually even
happen and then there was kind of like a
research of energy because we had a new
goal we had a new destination point and
we were suddenly moving towards the 2021
olympics so um within our team there was
a lot of growth a lot of new energy and
just everyone kind of
came together to support each other and
take on a new role within the team which
was so cool to see i think i started
saying it's even longer than that this
goes back to childhood to when you know
i was joking with you about on the swim
team water polo was our day off on
friday and that's how some people fall
in love with it but this is something
you've worked towards your whole life
yeah and i didn't have a typical olympic
journey i didn't have the dream when i
was really young and part of that is
because i didn't see people who look
like me in the sport when i was younger
but for a lot of our teammates this has
been
in the works since they were very young
and they set that olympic dream early
and they pursued it so celebrating that
with them celebrating um my also
individual olympic dream coming true
it's it means the world to all of us you
want to try to change that idea when you
say you didn't see somebody who looked
like you in the sport it is a very white
sport water polo period swimming even
more so how are you trying to change
that so the first thing that i had to do
to change that and to like realize my
role in it was to understand the context
of exclusion and inclusion in aquatic
spaces for people of color and just
understand why there weren't more people
who look like me in the sport in
aquatics in general and then i realized
that
it's a huge responsibility but it's a
responsibility that i had the
opportunity to welcome and that i could
welcome by literally just being here i
could just be a mirror that a young
black girl or a young black boy could
look to and see themselves in and i
realized how powerful that was and how
powerful that could be for someone who's
coming into our sport and maybe has
heard the stereotype that black people
don't swim or
looked and
didn't see anyone who didn't who
looked like them and just kind of got
discouraged so
it's part of my mission to change that
it's definitely inspiring i think we
also need to talk about how difficult
water polo is it made a break day for
swimmers but that's only because
swimming is a boring
the back and problem in the pictures
that we showed introducing you ashley
you're in the pool and it looks like
you're standing on solid ground with
your arms in the air or diving but of
course you're not you're treading water
the whole time how do you stay in sha do
you get
it's
full body strength like i always talk
about how water polo isn't just
what you see like we look really calm
from here up right we're constantly
working underwater it takes a lot of leg
strength it takes a lot of arms i push
with my hands and do like a huge brush
stroke kick for people who know what a
breaststroke kick is to lunge to block
the ball but also it's a game that
requires a lot of intelligence like as a
goalkeeper i'm constantly making reads
i'm um communicating to my defense
what's open i'm manipulating like a lot
of different things in the water
including my own body to try to make
that stop to try to make a pass to like
stop the other team from scoring and
it's just such a fun game and you do
have to be very strong so let me ask you
about your journey how you got to be an
olympian i mean you talked about being a
catalyst for change for young black boys
and girls going forward but what was it
like for you when you first stepped into
the pool um i stepped into a pool and
my journey with aquatics with water polo
has always been about fun so i didn't
love swimming because
it's boring sometimes it really is yeah
i'm sorry a little bit boring i was like
singing in my head i was like okay we
just get small like flip turn but yeah
my family was there my social life is
there like i just had fun with it and i
continue to have fun with it to this day
and that's why i can stay here so long
but i grew up in a family of five
children we had a pool in our backyard
learned to swim from a jamaican olympian
which i wasn't aware of when i was young
but you didn't know that
they were an olympian i didn't know that
she was an olympian
it was amazing um like looking back at
the whole journey now but um we learned
to swim together and just grew so much
together in the sport that uh
i really highly recommend
so you never you had you didn't you had
blockers on in other words when you
would show up at the pool and let's say
you were the only person of color there
you didn't that didn't phase you that
didn't phase me because i grew up with
my siblings in the sport and we had a
lot of support um within our club team
growing up so when i left in high school
like going to the national team going to
college i became more and more aware of
other people's perception of me and
whether or not i should be there
but i was already developing like the
protective mechanisms you know the
things that i told myself about myself
the stories that i had about myself that
i knew didn't confirm those stories like
you probably shouldn't be swimming like
what about your hair what about like all
of these things and
i hope that me being here kind of breaks
through those
stories that other people tell young
black kids and aquatics about themselves
so that
they don't even have to doubt they don't
even question whether or not they belong
here because we belong here we're strong
we excel in aquatics and there's so much
opportunity you more than excel real
quickly i know you just finished an
olympia but will there be potentially a
third gold medal for you another
olympics for you i don't wanna there's
always potential there's always um
the journey but if anything i've learned
in the past year and a half is that you
can't predict what's gonna happen you
can't
i can't say where i'm gonna be in three
years but i hope it's at the top of the
podium again and i hope it's with this
team interesting there's a lot of
potential on that side of the table on
this side of the table not so much
[Laughter]
we're so proud of you congratulations
thanks for letting
johnson you're amazing